we are asked to find the missing value
and they give us a hint use the number
line to find the missing value and let's
see they say 4 plus something is equal
to negative 6. so why don't you pause
this video and see if you can work
through this before we do it ourselves
all right so let's just start at four so
there's a couple of ways to think about
it we could just say where is four on
the number line four is here one two
three four we're going to start there
and we're going to add something to that
4 to get us to negative 6 to get us
right there
so what are we going to add well we're
going to be moving to the left so we're
going to be adding a negative number
right over here and we can see what that
negative number is going to be how many
units do we have to move to the left we
have to move one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten to the left
so what do we add if we want to move 10
to the left we have to add a negative
10. so this is negative 10 right over
here another way to think about it if
you're 4 to the right of 0 well it's
going to take you 4 just to get back to
zero that's four there and it's going to
take you another 6 to get you to
negative 6 and then of course you're
moving to the left so that's going to be
a negative 10. let's do another example
scroll down a bit so we can see that
second example so once again find the
Miss find the missing value and pause
this video again and try to work that
out
all right so there's a couple of ways we
can think about it we're saying negative
3 is equal to something plus five so
let's just see where negative 3 is on
this number line negative 3 is right
over there and something plus 5 is going
to be equal to negative 3. so plus five
you could view it as you're going to
start someplace and you're going to move
five units to the right something like
that to get to where you end up so where
could we start to get five units to the
right and be at negative three well if
we just go five units to the left so 1 2
3 4 5. if you start from this point and
you were to add five you were to get to
negative three and so what is this point
right over here well this right over
here let's see this is negative 5
negative 6 negative seven negative eight
so we have negative eight plus five is
equal to negative three another way to
think about it is you could have used a
commutative property to say hey instead
of blank plus five you could say this is
negative three is equal to five plus
blank and so you can say let's start at
five let me just in another color let's
start at five
and then what would I have to add to it
to get to negative three and so well I
would have to move to the left
five and then three in order to get to
negative three so you would essentially
have to add negative eight so that's
another way that you could think about
that